so what does that even mean here now
with more oversight committee chairman
James Comer all right so you're going to
hold direct array and contempt uh is
that what you said even though you have
a scheduled call with them where does it
stand tonight
well today was the deadline he was given
three weeks to produce a document and go
into detail on what exactly they did to
investigate the validity of the document
but thus far he won't even admit that
they have the document Sean he's given
us the runaround for three weeks he's
just stalling he said there's good faith
effort they haven't produced anything
they haven't even admitted they have a
document so we don't have confidence in
director Ray we're already in the
process of drafting legislation to hold
an oversight committee markup next week
to hold FBI director Ray in contempt of
congress all right let me ask you though
most people don't know what a 1023 form
is but my understanding of it is a
witness that you both you and Senator
Grassley describe as a credible witness
that makes a very specific allegation
that certain actions were taken by them
Vice President Biden in exchange for
money going to his family okay and and
that credible Witnesses brought that to
you and you want to see the document now
if that's uncorroborated by the FBI that
would be something probably that would
be seen in private I would guess number
two uh I want to know if the when the
FBI had this document knew about this
and what they did to investigate this
they've had the document for four years
we don't know if they've even
investigated it that's my fear that they
never did anything which you look at
what's happened with the IRS with the
IRS what's the Blower's claim is they
were told to stand down there's a
pattern within our federal government of
when looking at any type of wrongdoing
by the Biden family that people in the
government bureaucracy have told Rank
and file
government employees to stand down or or
to give them the file and don't worry
about it that's basically what director
Ray has told me I have demonstrated a
pattern of Joe Biden traveling all over
the world and weeks after he leaves the
country his family starts mysteriously
getting wires from that foreign country
into shell companies that then are wired
back to the individual family Bank let
me ask you that's not normal behavior
what would con what would the contempt
of the FBI director look like all right
you've now given them two opportunities
you have a phone call with them
um they're saying they're cooperating
but they're not going to give you the
document
um of course your committee and Congress
has uh not only a right but a duty in
terms of oversight
um what would what would a subpoena look
like in your view or contempt uh
ultimately if Congress look like well
we're still drafting but it's going to
look very similar to what the Democrats
did with Steve Bannon I mean that that
was a perfect example of a congressional
committee holding someone in contempt of
congress but for director Ray to issue a
statement
if I if my memory serves me it didn't
matter matter for Eric Holder and others
that were held in contempt you know it
seems like those rules only apply to
conservatives Congressman but we're
going to do everything we can to hold
him accountable and we're not messing
around we've already demonstrated a
pattern of behavior here that would
suggest this is a credible accusation
and we want answers
all right Congressman Comer great thank
you for that up hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else